we all know the iconic movie the titanic
but at the luxor titanic the artifact
exhibition takes us beyond the film and
onto the ship okay telling its stories
the real actual artifacts so let's
travel back to 1912 with artifact
specialist marisa lujan welcome thank
you for having me of course of course
now i was you know fascinated with
leonardo dicaprio growing up but also
the history behind the titanic so let's
talk about you know you're taking us
back to this part of the in the
exhibition to the dining experience
right 110 years ago yes let's talk about
it all right so uh the dining atmosphere
on titanic it was on the titanic was
designed to be unsurpassed
service and accommodations for all
classes of passengers
the food was for first and second class
was created in the same kitchen so
second class was eating food of the same
quality as first class for third class
on that fateful night of april 14 1912
they dined on dishes such as roast beef
and plum pudding food that they would
have only likely had about once or twice
a year
wow and they were eating these they were
eating these dishes on actual china that
they brought and utensils that they
brought onto the ship from their own
homes right some of them yes they
brought their own china with them they
were
immigrating to the united states so they
were taking all their belongings with
them we have some examples of that
personal china in the exhibit wow we'll
show it off show it off um so these are
pieces of the these are replicas that we
sell in our gift shop as well as online
these are examples of the third class
service wear as you can see the name
titanic doesn't appear on these dishes
that is because they could use them on
other white star aligned ships
this is an example of some of the first
class service where used in the first
class reception room and the veranda
cafe wow and you guys sell this stuff
yes we do so people can you know kind of
emulate the titanic at their own homes
um so what else can we ex or experience
at the exhibit it's not just the dining
experience the entire ship right we have
over 300 artifacts on display from the
titanic
including a 15 ton piece of the hull
which we've nicknamed the big piece okay
as well as some of those passenger
belongings like their personal china
postcards even um clothing that has
survived because it was inside that
leather luggage oh my god that's so
interesting so when you walk into the
exhibit what's the experience like for
four people who are in there are they
just walking through and looking are
they able to touch something um you you
get to walk in you see those artifacts
they were recovered between 1987 and
2004 you also get to see replica rooms
of some of the cabins the grand
staircase the promenade deck so you
really get that experience of what it
was like to be on the ship that is so
amazing great for the family but also a
fun um
kind of romantic date night for
valentine's day too right yes i would
say okay how can people get tickets and
enjoy so you can purchase tickets in
person at the luxor box office or online
at titanic las vegas
dot com we're open every day 11 a.m to 6
p.m with last entry at 5 p.m awesome
thank you so
thank you that's much
okay so there are today's all-stars and
tomorrow's legends